Speaker 1: So we've already done an exposé
Speaker 2: of Fox News's hypocrisy
Speaker 1: on vaccine requirements on air. We've
got the Fox hosts in particular Tucker Carlson,
Laura Ingraham, Hannity entertaining
this stuff as well. The daytime shows.
Dan Bongino, you know, the whole crew. They've
been softly and sometimes not so softly pushing
Speaker 2: against vaccines,
Speaker 1: promoting unproven treatments
and cures, certainly against the vaccine
Speaker 2: requirement, very
Speaker 1: aggressively
Speaker 2: against them. And yet
behind the scenes, we learned that
Speaker 1: Fox News has an even stricter
vaccination policy than the one that Joe Biden
proposed. You've got to not only be vaccinated,
but if you aren't, you've got to be testing
daily rather than weekly and you've got
to be wearing a mask. OK, we talked about it
already. We know about the Fox News hypocrisy.
But what about Newsmax? Because Newsmax,
the even further right network? Has been
completely off the rails in an even wackier
Speaker 2: way than Fox News on vaccines.
Speaker 1: COVID and COVID related conspiracies
and it turns out that this week Newsmax had
a holiday party in New York City and yes,
Speaker 2: everyone had to present proof of
Speaker 1: vaccination in order to attend
a negative test alone would not suffice.
Speaker 2: You must show your vaccination
Speaker 1: card or a picture of your vaccination
card. Here's the notice that Newsmax
Speaker 2: sent out,
Speaker 1: which says
Speaker 2: Reminder on
Speaker 1: Newsmax Holiday Reception City
regulations require that you show a vaccination
card. A COVID test alone is not sufficient.
Speaker 2: Now, Newsmax
Speaker 1: made completely clear that
as a company, they have no vaccine
requirement whatsoever. This is a requirement
Speaker 2: for this particular holiday party
Speaker 1: because it's in New York City
Speaker 2: and these are New York City
rules. But wouldn't you think that if this
Speaker 1: goes against their principles,
if they are so opposed to any such requirement,
wouldn't they put their money where their mouth
is and stand in defiant
Speaker 2: opposition?
Have the party in some other state?
Speaker 1: Have the party at a private
residence find some way around it? Like
it doesn't seem like it would be that hard
right now in their defense? And you know, I have
no interest in. I want to encourage good behavior,
not just call out bad behavior. Newsmax has
parted ways with a couple of the wackier, anti-vax
Speaker 2: people that they've had on air.
Speaker 1: There's this guy Steve Cortez,
former Trump adviser. He recently left the network
as a primetime host, for example, and he was very
Speaker 2: publicly against
Speaker 1: Newsmax vaccine rules.
And sources told The Daily
Speaker 2: Beast that
Speaker 1: it was because of that
loud opposition to his employer's own
Speaker 2: rules. It was sort of the last straw.
Speaker 1: Steve Cortez and Newsmax parted ways.
We talked three weeks ago, maybe it
was more like four or five weeks ago,
the White House correspondent Emerald Robinson
from Newsmax. She was in bonkers cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs land, tweeting about bioluminescent
tracking devices in the vaccine. And what else
was she talking about? Luciferase and
Speaker 2: give you
Speaker 1: something? Did she talk about a
black light? I don't even remember anyway.
She is not coming back to the network after her
completely off the wall claims about the vaccine.
So good for Newsmax. As far as that goes, I've
actually had a couple of very polite exchanges
with some some higher ups at Newsmax that
they're not obviously crazy. It does seem like
Speaker 2: it's for
Speaker 1: money, meaning it's
Speaker 2: sort of a Griveaux
Speaker 1: thing that Newsmax is operating. Maybe
I'll say more about that in the future. I don't
want to sort of out anybody there. But Newsmax
clearly not standing in opposition strongly enough
to vaccine requirements to say we are going to a
private residence or will do it in. I don't know
what the rules are in New Jersey, but maybe we'll
do it over the river in New Jersey or somewhere
else. They are just going with the rules and
Speaker 2: it is not a shock
Speaker 1: given what we've seen
Fox News do and all of these other complete and
total hypocrites. Let me know your thoughts about
that. We'll have more coverage of this on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show we will take a quick break. A lot of exciting
things coming up on the program in mere moments.